з початком наступу російських військ з
півночі цей правий берег київського моря
у лютому опинився під окупацією кілька
сіл росіяни не контролювали та люди тут
були відрізаними від світу на це їхня
смерть тут ми живемо в такому
закобанчику що тут далі по воді или не
можна если б їх тут зажали то їм будуть
за кілька тижнів в ізоляції у місцевих
почали закінчуватися харчі багатьом
потрібно була медична допомога тоді
рибалки вирішили влаштувати переправу на
інший вільний берег Київського
водосховища все почалося Ой Коли стало
питання треба було у селі була вагітна
жінка
який було призначено строк і треба було
щоб вона народжувала Ну там без всяких
цих у лікарні крига була така там де по
три де по 5 см ну цей рейс був дуже
такий небезпечний Ну але доїхали туди
першим рейсом по воді поверталася до
своїх рідних Анжела жінка приїхала у
Страхолісся за день до повномасштабного
вторгнення і потім не змогла виїхати із
села бо російські війська вже стояли в
Іванкові
12 березня Ми якраз виїжджали з цією
вагітною дівчиною ми були перші кого
вивезли страшно було ми буквально
розбивали лід але трималися якось
підтримували одне одного
поддерживали
рибалки щодня ризикували бо могли
загинути від кулі чи штормової хвилі та
сотні людей з навколишніх сіл тікали від
окупації і просили про допомогу он там
дальше Януковича
І от стався сторона
ми переїжджали на ту чернігівську
сторону а так по прямує потом понадтою
стороною вже
у цю лодку клали три матраси там
були такі не нові клали щоб було людям
хоч якось от сідало до 16 чоловіків
Спочатку вивозили то люди які
потребували якогось медикаментозного
лікування
дітей потім які
старі люди на вільний берег вони
вивозили людей а звідти забрали
гуманітарну допомогу і постачали в
ізольовані села там на лівому березі їм
допомагав Костянтин власник риболовної
бази только всё страха есть я и прочие
было тільки села Страхолісся та інших
було реально лише з адресними посилками
орієнтовно 70 тон гуманітарки передано і
десь дві майже трохи більше тисячі людей
з того берега але набагато було більше
гуманітарки людей з боку Сухолуччя
толокуня ясногородки диммера
переправлено
під час гарної погоди рейс стрибав 40
хвилин лише в один бік у такому ритмі
рибалки рятували людей майже місяць
найбільше водних переправ зробив
Олександр до трьох Щодня я їздив на ту
сторону до сторони там де орки були но
вони там не зайшли в одне село і там
були такі
в нас определённый Белый балкон мы туда
поддержали это тоже оттуда забирали
людей перевозили сначала на страхолісі
мали маленьких дітей 16 человек этот
адаптер його за одну ходку вообще
грудних спиляли а вночі перевозив із
костяної бази зброю боєкомплекти та
добровольців у тил до росіян для
зачистки мені вже приїхала Карпатська
Січ до мене приїхала Карпатська Січ
заїхало понад 100 людей ми з усіма
хлопцями вже були навчені людей возили
організували усе допомогли знайомі та
деякі мої чом не були і це все
перекинули на гору до Білорусі сначала
вечорами ночами возили потім іностранные
Легион сопровождали
Ну багато було а потом
Сначала я розвідку завез на Нептун
на следующий день взяли ну цей же день
взяли ніптом по своїй контролем
завершення операції Нептун
Слава Україні
рибалки зізнаються було страшно часом
серед київського моря переставав
працювати мотор і вітер ніс човен у
плавні до росіян Та вони відчували свій
обов'язок допомагати людям другий раз
стріляло другий раз
можете представити як було їздити щоб
мені жена каже на мене тобі надо Ти один
тут в селі Ти дитині 4 роки не кажу мені
надо вивозять їх ми знали ми знали що ми
робимо
погану орком що це менше заручників це
менше
потенційних
постраждалих від чогось такого там що
воно буде як вони зайдуть у села хтозна
стимулювали виходити на воду і
перелякані очі дітей з ізольованого
Страхолісся рибалки вивезли маленьку Аню
дівчинка жила там із бабусею поки батьки
працювали у Києві пробний раз поїхала
вагітна а уже в другий рейс поїхала моя
дитину
Було дуже страшно насправді поки її
везли
я не можу передати словами
що я відчувала Да поки її везли
Это мой друг мене весь дядько Толя Це
мій друг який дуже любить рибалку у
нього хороший човен і він дуже довго
мене віз мене накрили ковдрою щоб мені
було не холодно я приїхала на інший
берег і сказала військовим Слава Україні
Героям слава
нашій Україні
Героям слава крім щоденних переправ
рибалки ловили рибу роздавали її жителям
навколишніх сіл та возили у будинок
літніх людей відсиджуватися вдома не
могли і намагалися зробити свій внесок у
спільну справу